it's really appropriate that they
release a batman trailer after
the biggest holiday of the year you know
killing
the holiday do you guys get where i'm d
do any of you get where i'm going with
this joke do any of you get where i'm
going with this
do you holiday the whole the holiday
killer oh my god for a second holiday
kills really like i don't think john
goes i regret the long halloween
all right guys we're gonna watch the
batman the bat and the cat trailer this
is essentially a trailer three i'm just
gonna treat this like it's the third
trailer right house would you treat it
like it's the third trailer yeah
holiday killer that [ __ ] cracks me up
[Music]
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
you have no idea lady
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
wow i love these shots
goddamn man and that film grain is
asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
good there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
cats
everything about straight
the bat and the cat
gotham empire you're part of this too
still how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
all these
dude my nipples are so hard
selena don't throw your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find holy
[ __ ] damn
the answer's justice
adjusted come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
oh look at that smoke show oh the
cinematography is so beautiful it's so
beautiful oh another cipher too
who's going to crack it
i heard that it this is going to come on
hbo max 45 days after it releases
that's when we should watch it screw the
waiters for hp
hbo max this one really is showcased too
i remember koi was bringing up in the
last trailer reaction what he was saying
was how that one really seemed like that
this would also be like half of
catwoman's movie in some way or at least
like a third of catwoman's movie and the
fact that wb is leading with the bat in
the cat trailer and just how much celine
kyle that we get here sort of how she
represents like more of the lower class
of selena kyle where you're dealing with
the corrupt wealthy and she's like
dealing with the people that she
actually cares about this really does
feel like at least a third of this movie
will be hers man maybe even half would
like but it seems like she's essentially
the main supporting character but i mean
come on guys
we'll talk about the story but holy crap
the action looks insane the more we get
about the action i just eat it up like
even the expansion that we get on
certain scenes like with penguin and
batman the car chase action scene
everything at the end with like the
smoke i just love it there's something
that just feels so damn tangible about
this whole the whole way all this is
being captured it's so visceral and
intense like it just grips you at the
heart every single fight scene and then
even the hand-to-hand stuff was it
wasn't looking like the best with the
catwoman in batman but there is
something more about like the sexual
tension underneath it that you're like
yeah i can see how these guys would want
to get it on i didn't see why those
rumors started about robert pattinson
ming and zoe kravitz on the batmobile i
believe those now they're 100 true from
that one little moment we got here the
way they're shooting that car chase with
all those different like locked off
shots it really puts you almost in the
perspective of the batmobile itself
which is like a great way to tweak that
because yeah this is you know further
down the rabbit hole of grit and
perspective and two i mean i love the
way that yeah this is all about the bat
and the cat but the riddler in this
trailer seems to loom even more
ominously and menacingly than in the
previous ones i mean i feel like we got
the clearer shots of him too yeah yeah i
feel like the previous ones play up like
yeah he's the mastermind but they play
up the sort of like unlikely
just person that that is with the brief
glimpses they show whereas here it
really does feel like he is this sort of
monster who is bringing the city to a
reckoning and seeing these like shots of
mass destruction too these explosions
going off and streets flooding it really
does
make it look like a new caliber or
something that is freshly intense by
comparison because we've seen a lot of
intense stuff in the previous batman
movies the amount of untraceable
facetime calls that he is making in this
one trailer alone i think edward nash
just really wants to have a friend
that's what a lot of this is lonely
there's a part of him that seems like
he's sort of longing for a connection
with bruce wayne specifically oh yeah
like it's already established in the
first show that he knows that batman
really is bruce wayne it's like he
almost wants to elevate bruce to his
level you know he's looking for that
equal for him to match but he also
really wants him to uncover a secret and
it does really seem like they're going
down the path that's possible to lead
towards the court of owls the way how it
seems with the wayne family that they
are going to explore the site of the
wayne family that was ultimately dealing
with corruption as well so a lot of this
will also be about how bruce wayne seems
like he just wants to escape and only
play batman this entire time he's going
to have to figure out a way to redefine
the wayne legacy as well redefine what
it means to be a wayne well i love that
too because
matt reeves said he kind of envisioned
this version of bruce less like yeah
billionaire playboy more like reclusive
kirk cobain type and so i like too that
this trailer is is really honing in on
it's a bunch of people pulling at bruce
batman to do what they believe is the
right thing and so you're watching as
these different entanglements form
between the cops the riddler catwoman
this is this emissary who's talking to
him in the beginning of the trailer
about you your family used to be into
philanthropy but you're not doing
anything yeah you know all the different
ways you could affect this situation who
was that a character mine immediately
just goes up vicki vale that's exactly
where my mind goes to your guess is is
it better than mine i don't know that's
where my mind would at least venture to
guess one thing that i think that this
that all three trailers have managed to
do though in spite of how grandiose it
is and how epic it always feels is that
they constantly feel intimate personal
and very dark especially i love the way
how they really brought it into the
wayne side of things as well because
he's everything that he's doing seems to
be motivated by a strong purpose so if
he's going to get more involved than
being bruce wayne unless batman it has
to be motivated by something that feels
like he he has to redefine something in
some way the way how he wants to help
redefine gotham by being batman also
like it just looks like it's gonna be
heartbreaking in so many ways too
everything with selena kyle in him looks
like it'll eventually end in some level
of heartbreak everything with alfred
seems there's gonna be some real drama
to ring out of that too because alfred
knows the secrets of the wayne family
uh the way how he's working with the
cops on the cops not trusting him like
there's so much here to deal with so
many moving chess pieces i can't wait
guys what did you think about this
trailer this looks incredible to me
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button we'll catch you guys soon what a
way to end off the year
you